welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is my reaction to the new
trailer black panther what kind of
forever will I cry maybe will I oversell
the crap out of some parts of it and
scream let's go like an idiot probably
will I react to this go through the
highlights and share my initial thoughts
before returning to my hole to break it
down frame by frame for an in-depth
trailer breakdown that comes out
tomorrow definitely let's react to this
trailer so I can get along with that
virtual ticket Cube for this oh my God
you we go
all right
foreign
oh man
I love this music so much
this is uh I think this is Santa the
Great
oh wow okay they're actually going
forward
I love this this is stuff we saw d23
he know what he whisper
what hey
they lost
one time
let's go
show them
who we are
huh
[Music]
oh
okay but how many are there that's my
question I think that's just one New
Black Panther suit we're gonna see I
don't think they would show that and
that's the only New Black Panther I
think we're gonna see quite a few in
this movie that's my guess I mean based
off of the form the silhouette that
looks a lot like shuri shuri's front and
center on the poster doing the pose I I
think that's Siri right there though the
musical view here is specifically the
sound of the door melange so uh so we
could be looking at Okoye here but let's
not forget Nakia was a former member of
the door melange so she could also be
the one in the suit I feel like I've
said since the beginning that one
possible way that they could go in this
is to give the suit to multiple
characters so that at least during the
run time of this movie they wouldn't say
this one character is the definitive
Legacy wearing the black panther suit
and then by the end of the movie they
could settle on one of them or hint at
one of them this character is landing in
a Snowy Mountain setting so looks like
the mountain tribe the Jabari will be
the point of Refuge for the characters
of The Golden City where they have to
retreat to after Neymar and his allies
attack the main city this does look like
the same suit if not ever very similar
suit to the one that ended the last
trailer in July there's the same golden
trim on the calves and I believe that is
the open mom of the Panther on The
Gauntlet and when we discovered that in
July we were like oh that's very similar
to the uh to the panther Gauntlet
weapons that sure he uses at the end of
the 2018 film we also noticed the dot
patterns on the mask not too dissimilar
from the face paint that shuri is
wearing ceremonially during t'challa's
funeral there's probably a lot more
detail in this I'm going to break them
properly in the breakdown that we
released tomorrow let's talk about the
music of this trailer it's a beautiful
song Choice called Never Forget by sampa
the great featuring Chef 187 Teo Nason
and juanji a stamp of the great is a
Zambian singer and rappers based out of
Australia and this song is considered a
tribute to what's called zamrock zamrock
is like a musical genre from the 70s
that was rooted in Zambia It's a
combination of traditional African music
but with psychedelic Rock and garage
Rock and Hard Rock it's kind of been
described as a combined sound of Jimi
Hendrix and James Brown you hear all
different parts of the song here
including the main theme but also the
rap break if you take a look at the
lyrics of it it's really perfect for
this story opening with who took a
fabric made that [ __ ] classic
specifically talking about this idea of
the fabric the vibranium weed that goes
into the suit and literally in this lore
which character actually designed these
suits who stitched them together it was
shuri in a lab now we're always hungry
right like yes hungry for the latest
Easter eggs hungry for the newest
trailers hungry for more movies and
shows featuring our favorite Heroes and
stars but also just like literally
hungry the amount of time I have to
think about food vastly outpaces the
amount of time I have to get and prepare
tasty meals which is why I love to use
factor and yeah I know I've said the
same thing about hellofresh and that's
because both are true factor is now
owned by hellofresh which means that
there's a wider array of meal plans to
choose from I switched between both
Brands and now new rockstars viewers can
do the same thing while getting a
discounted deal on food you know the
thing I'm still thinking about Factor
cuts out stressful meal planning and
extensive prepping so meals come
together in minutes taking the guesswork
out of what to make for breakfast lunch
or dinner Factor meals arrive
pre-prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes even faster than ordering
takeout
dinner time
[Music]
hit us my dinner
I'm really good see how easy that was
eating well should always be this easy
one of the things I like about factor is
how it makes it possible to achieve your
daily fitness goals through nutritious
purposeful eating Factor offers keto
calorie smart Chef's Choice and vegan
plus veggie options which include
Seafood meat and plant-based meals meal
plans offer variety with a rotating
weekly menu of 25 plus meal options and
Factor plus add-ons choose your favorite
meals or let Factor craft your order
based on your taste preferences and your
meal history to get started with Factor
today head to
go.factor75.com
rockstars60 and use the code rockstar60
to get 60 off your first Factor box
again that site is
go.factor75.com
rockstars60 and use the code rockstars60
to get 60 off your first Factor box and
as we think about shuri making her suit
in this trailer it also makes us think
about the parallel figure in this movie
Riri Williams ironheart making her new
suit which we actually see a lot of in
this photo yeah we see a really quick
blurry shot of her suit as it's chasing
someone down and then the classic Iron
Man style heads up display of Riri in
the suit screaming let's go now a lot of
this footage is pretty similar to what
we saw in d23 all the stuff with Ramona
saying we've heard you whisper you lost
your protector this all comes from under
speech at the U.N which assuming the U.S
delegate and the French delegate who are
coming at her for not sharing the
vibranium resources saying they could be
used for weapons of mass destruction
meanwhile we see French soldiers raiding
this Mali Outreach Center and then by
the end the door melange bring these
soldiers back in shaming everybody but
there's also a lot of new footage of
Namor and that's I think my favorite
part of this trailer specifically that
this character can fly and not just
float around he could definitely Dart
around the air he's a really difficult
Target to hit but maku explains an even
greater challenge you don't necessarily
want to hit him he almost has this
Untouchable status as the Avatar of the
deity named kukul Khan this is actually
a name that I brought up in our trailer
breakdown in July the Mayan feathered
serpent deity this is the art that we
see Neymar looking at at the beginning
of the trailer so in the way that the
Black Panther is considered the Avatar
of the panther deity of Bost Neymar has
his own roots and Mayan and Aztec
mythology Marcus says that killing him
will risk Eternal War so what does that
mean does that mean that Namor is kind
of this one protecting figure holding it
all together and if you take him out
then there's nothing to stop the more
extremist factions of Tallulah Khan from
attacking wakanda because right now it
seems like Neymar has no problem doing
that it just puts all these shots of
Namor in wakanda under a different
context like he may be kind of a
pacifist who's been driven to this point
of war and trying to hold back the more
dangerous factions of his Lions it also
puts a different context under these
opening words that we hear from Neymar I
think so far the only dialogue we've
heard from Neymar only the most broken
people can be great leaders it almost
sounds like advice that he's giving to
one of the women who's grieving t'challa
they've been so broken by losing him
that that's going to be a form of power
for them I think what excites me the
most about this footage is we still know
a little more about the plot than we did
at the beginning of all this than we did
back in July we know that t'challa will
be dying or will have died at the
beginning of the story but we still
don't really know what caused that we
know at least one new female character
will be wearing a new vibranium suit we
know that Namor and the other atlanteans
from swallow con will be attacking
wakanda but we don't know exactly why
but we do know that there's some kind of
looming War over vibranium on the planet
of Earth right now and that the outside
world represented by the UN and other
forces are trying to plunder it but that
was also kind of the story of the 2018
film so this has been like an ongoing
thing and now it's just come to a
Boiling Point now that t'challa is no
longer the leader I am so ready for this
movie I can't wait to break down not
only this trailer but to break down the
whole movie when I get to see it because
I think the coolest thing that Ryan
coogler does in these movies is takes
real world influences and stitches it
into the fabric of these characters
wardrobe and everything that they are
wearing on them from their jewelry to
their makeup to their costumes is all
deeply rooted in the cultures that
they're coming from and every part of it
contributes to the story and you can see
that not only in the clothes they're
wearing whether it's for a funeral or in
some kind of Royal ceremony but in the
new tech that they wear as well I
believe in the 2018 film there was
actually wakan in letters that were
stitched into t'challa's outfit that
literally said like I love you in it
like Ryan coogler put that in for his
own mom so when you're looking at the
apparel here you're not crazy to look at
the little details and the design
details because that's where the most
beautiful parts of the movie are hidden
I can't wait for this movie I think we
all really really need it and I think
it's gonna be a beautiful way to end
phase four let me know your favorite
part of this trailer in the comments
below again my Easter egg breakdown is
coming out on the trailer tomorrow I'm
gonna need some time to really go
through it frame by frame you can follow
me on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
eat a boss follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you